[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for security
policy while Americans are becoming
increasingly familiar with leftist
authoritarianism and opposition to the
freedom of speech fewer people are aware
that there is an all-out international
islamic jihad against the stand a tional
freedom nor do many people realize how
often leftists and Islamic supremacists
work hand in hand to curtail the freedom
of speech here are six recent such
collaborations as I explained in more
detail in my book the complete infidels
guide to free speech and its enemies
Obama versus the First Amendment given
the First Amendment the Obama
administration couldn't move directly to
restrict speech critical of Islam but it
did find creative ways to try to ensure
that the First Amendment right to free
speech would be tailored in an
appropriate way particularly when it
came to speech about Islam one way the
Obama administration attempted to
curtail the First Amendment was at the
United Nations in October 2009 the US
government lent its support to a UN
Human Rights Council resolution
declaring that negative racial and
religious stereotyping should be
outlawed the resolution stated that UN
member states should condemn and
criminalize any advocacy of national
racial or religious hatred that
constitutes incitement to discrimination
hostility or violence against
discrimination but who would decide that
an unacceptable level of national racial
or religious hatred had been reached
incitement to violence is relatively
easy to spot but incite them to
hostility is very much in the eye of the
beholder
just as they would do with House
Resolution 569 members of the US
government were working to advance the
Muslim campaign against the freedom of
speech by deliberately conflating speech
and even feelings with actual violent
crimes DNC chair refuses to say he won't
move to criminalized criticism of Islam
in July 2012 Thomas Perez the Obama
administration's assistant attorney
general for the Civil Rights Division
who later became chair of the Democratic
National Committee after Donald Trump
was elected president was being
questioned by Republican representative
Trent Franks of Arizona about the Obama
administration's commitment to free
speech
will you tell us here today Frank's
asked that this administration's
Department of Justice will never
entertain or advance a proposal that
criminalizes speech against any religion
Peres could have simply answered yes and
maybe even cited the First Amendment
instead he refused to answer the
question directly
Frank's persisted ultimately asking it
four times at one point Peres claimed
that it was a hard question he simply
refused to affirm that the Obama Justice
Department would not attempt to
criminalize criticism of Islam
now while the Obama administration
indeed never did go so far it Nebel de
round the edges of the First Amendment
in numerous ways to appease Muslim
sensibilities and thereby set a
disturbing precedent laying a foundation
upon which criminalization of certain
kinds of speech may be justified in the
future one way they did that of course
was by blaming Benghazi on offending the
Muslims the initiative to cater to
Muslims easily offended feelings got a
massive boost from the massacre of four
Americans by Islamic Jihad EES in
Benghazi Libya on September 11th 2012
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton's
initial statement on the violent attack
suggested that it was a spontaneous
reaction to a YouTube video the
innocence of Muslims which was critical
of Mohammed and other administration
officials would make that claim outright
including Susan Rice Clinton took the
opportunity to deplore not only the
violence but also the criticism of Islam
that was supposed to have motivated it
some have sought to justify this vicious
behavior as a response to inflammatory
material posted on the Internet she said
the United States deplores any
international effort to denigrate the
religious
leaves of others our commitment to
religious tolerance goes back to the
very beginning of our nation but let me
be clear this is never any justification
for violent acts of this kind now that
was for public consumption
behind closed doors however Secretary of
State Clinton told egyptians egypt's
Muslim Brotherhood Prime Minister Hassan
Khan deal the very next day we know that
the attack in Libya had nothing to do
with the film it was a planned attack
not a protest based on the information
we saw today we believe the group that
claimed responsibility for this was
affiliated with al-qaeda
now while Obama's Justice Department
never did move to officially criminalize
criticism of Islam Obama appointed
officials occasionally acted as if they
had already done so in May 2013
Bill Killian the Obama appointed US
Attorney for the Eastern District of
Tennessee gave another indication of how
the First Amendment might be tailored in
an appropriate way so as to preclude
speech that the administration
considered insulting to Muslims
Kilian declared we need to educate
people about Muslims and their civil
rights and as long as we're here they're
going to be protected no problem with
that
everyone civil rights deserve protection
Kilian explained this is an educational
effort with civil rights laws as they
play in to freedom of religion and
exercising freedom of religion this is
also to inform the public what federal
laws are in effect and what the
consequences are the consequences that
is of exercising the freedom of speech
we saw this again in the summer of 2016
an Obama appointed federal prosecutor in
Idaho didn't even bother to go to war
against the First Amendment he simply
behaved as if it didn't exist three
Muslim migrants whose families had been
settled in a Twin Falls Idaho apartment
complex brutally sexually assaulted a
five-year-old girl who was their
neighbor in this overheated atmosphere
of charge and counter-charge when DJ
Olsen the Obama appointed US Attorney
for Idaho chose to warn Twin Falls
residents
others interested in the case that
speech about the case could be a crime
the spread of false information or
inflammatory or threatening statements
about the perpetrators or the crime
itself
she said reduces public safety and may
violate federal law the US Attorney's
primary concern which was shared by the
prosecutor appeared to be not justice
for the five-year-old rape victim but
for protecting the Muslim migrants
involved on December 3rd 2015 the day
after two muslims murdered 14 people at
a Christmas party in San Bernardino
California Attorney General Loretta
Lynch gave an address at the 10th
anniversary dinner of Muslim advocates
the groups that had been responsible for
the Obama administration's removal of
all mention of Islam in jihad from
counter terror training materials
despite the attack the previous day
Lynch was preoccupied not with Jihad
violence and how to stop it but with
what she claimed was an incredibly
disturbing rise of anti-muslim rhetoric
what is really disturbing is how the
assault on our most fundamental freedom
the freedom of speech continues under
our noses with hardly any pushback I'm
Robert Spencer
[Music]